you
[Music]
the drag on system support for AI and
the track is orchestrated by a very dear
friend of MSR India though he's no
longer with us
here in India attend to thicket
Chandu was in fact managing director of
inner India before she robbed him took
over from him and since then he's moved
now to Redmond but he still continues to
be a great friend of the lab Chandu is
it's too long to lead all his
achievement but I'll just quickly
summarize the distinguishing in engineer
at Microsoft and he began his career in
Microsoft at the turn of the century
almost 20 years now and he's worked
across you know multiple areas in
election dude we were talking for
himself here because he doesn't like to
wrong introductions and it's my pleasure
to invite Chandu to kick off the
afternoon tracking systems the only
thing I want the last time I gave a talk
at IIT Madras I was a fifth year
undergraduate in electronics so it's a
great pleasure to be back alright so
this thing this session was advertised
the session was advertised as a panel
discussion it's not going to be a panel
discussion which is going to run it like
a regular conference track I'll give you
a brief introduction with a few slides
on to motivate the track and then we'll
have three speakers who will each give
you a full-blown technical talk as you
would hear in a conference they'll
they'll talk for 25 minutes and then
there'll be Q&A in the end also good let
me see if I can get this to move all
right so if you look at the history of
AI by doing the admittedly crude
procedure of typing a query into Google
and you look for something like deep
learning as a proxy for machine learning
and AI you notice that
there is a knee there some time past
2011 maybe 2014 or so and prior to 2002
2004 it was pretty much non-existent on
the other hand if you look at the actual
theory that powers all the stuff that's
called a long history it's 1985 many of
you who are not doing computer science
then some of you may not have even
bonded so it's a long long there's a
long history there what so what what
makes this work what makes this work is
that we have and we may have had this
for maybe last four or five years a
significant amount of compute
infrastructure that you can dedicate to
these problems now if you think a little
bit about this we have seen this kind of
story before we have had fast CPUs we
have always wanted to run the best
shortest path algorithm on it but we
know you can't run an algorithm on a
piece of hardware until you build all
the stuff in between all the stuff in
between used to be called operating
systems the editors this that and the
other thing so I think of all of that
system support and that's the same thing
that's playing out here and you should
not be surprised whether a I will be the
future is less material than what do we
need to do now to enable all the AI
applications that are out there and to
do that it is useful to understand what
machine learning is at an abstract level
because if you're going to do systems
you need to sort of understand what is
actually going on the basic idea is that
you want to calculate a complicated
function from some data that you have
now one way you can do that is you can
write this enormously complicated
procedure with if-then-else especial
cases this that and the other thing lots
of rules or you can do machine learning
and infer which is the process of
learning the function f given a large
amount of data the operative words are
to infer by learning and the other one
is large amounts of data so you need to
sort of accommodate this large amount of
data which sort of teaches you what this
function is supposed to do you learn
that function and then in a separate
step called the influencing step embed
that function or model as you would call
it in AI parlance into your application
so that when it's given the data input
it computes the function it's very
straightforward so two things training
and influencing both of which we need
significant amount of systems the
driving forces I think if you look at
machine learning is essentially two
things okay three things there is plenty
of hardware that is available but we
need to do some high-performance
computing systems high-performance
system structure to make all those
computing available plus we need
advances in algorithms even with our
state-of-the-art algorithms that we have
now there is plenty of work to do in
both hardware and in in system software
which is why I said to maybe do enough
it's not that algorithms are not
important but even today the state of
the algorithms I think is quite far
advanced
I just want to sketch some potential
areas of systems research for those of
you who might be interested in doing
systems research and the three talks
that follow will will highlight in no
comprehensive way but highlight some of
the work that is going on currently in
in systems the first thing I said in the
previous couple of slides was that we
need to deal with massive amounts of
data if you have massive amounts of data
you know that it's quite a chore to
store that data in a fault-tolerant
fashion or in a scalable fashion curate
the data from various logs that you
might be using or various data sources
that are kind of raw you need to curate
that and having efficient access of the
data so that's a very central problem in
the central problem in dealing with the
data now
having the data and that thing stored is
not enough like you need to be able to
run a computation on that data to learn
something remember I told you a couple
of slides ago about learning a function
so how to make efficient use of hardware
to run your inference your training jobs
on this and the influencing jobs on the
data is an important thing and you'll
hear a talk later the last talk of sorry
the first talk of the session will be
talking about a one particular aspect of
of system infrastructure called for
elastic training and inferencing a
pretty big component of what makes
systems of search a what makes AI
possible is hardware innovation we all
know how to compute on CPUs GPUs are
also fairly in the mainstream but there
is a constant quest to think of more
exotic things like FPGAs and GPUs you
heard of both of them they're constantly
in the news on how they can train or
influence or model more efficiently and
this the second talk in this session is
going to talk about novel hardware
architectures how what how can you
enable new new hardware architectures to
do these kinds of things
the last bit is systems infrastructure
system software and my analogy as I said
earlier is that you want to run some
sort of algorithm on some piece of
hardware so there is a lot of things
that go into it even if so even though
you have the basic systems
infrastructure your hardware your
operating systems all done you still
have a lot of work to be done in
compiler optimizations for turning
algorithms make algorithms faster making
models faster it's quite an art form to
do this well
another issue is when you have these
special purpose processors of special
purpose devices they don't always like
to work on full 32-bit positions or you
can do much better if we can quantize
the data into
few of its opposition 8-bit 8-bit
position is very common people are
ambitious and they want to try even
lower so dealing with quantization
without losing your accuracy of the
model is a very hot area and a lot of
people work on that it's also related to
the previous topic the compiler
optimizations and another important area
which we will talk about in the session
is think about the people who have all
this data and who wanted to learn this
function that data is very proprietary
it is very high value and people do not
want to leak it or make it available to
other people so the idea of providing
anonymity due to legal requirements or
security for corporate you know for
corporate assets is a hot topic and how
do you do influencing and learning in
the presence of encryption or obscured
data is is also quite a hot challenge so
think of this list as areas that you
might want to do work in and the things
are in in italics the three talks the
resource elastic influencing and
training the hardware architectures and
the confidential computing or secure
computing those are the topics of the of
the three talks upon here so for the let
me quickly introduce the top talks today
the first talk is by muta and Savita
know and I'll introduce each speaker as
they come on I'm going to do the first
one now actually let me just give you
the whole list first and then I have
introduced okay so first paper is is
code designed for efficient DNN training
this is a paper that has been recently
published in multiple venues this work
has been published in multiple venues
and you can talk about that the next up
will be NCN which is talking about a new
machine that they're building at ETH
Timothy is going to tell you about that
and finally there is a talk on
cryptographic techniques to give you
better AI